all right let's hear from people in the
audience my favorite people we take
calls on the Friday show via Discord at
davidpackman.com Discord once you're
there you go to the waiting Lobby
and you raise your hand you click raise
hand that way I know you want to talk to
me and it's a very very exciting thing
let's go first this is just first this
isn't this isn't the be all end all
we're going to go first to Thai in Iowa
and see what is on Ty's mind Ty welcome
to the program
uh what's going on what's on your mind
today
hey David hey
how are you doing doing well oh okay
that's good all right um so I just
wanted to ask so you know how there was
the the riots and uh Brazil recently
right of course
yeah so
how how much do you think those were
probably inspired by January 6 do you
think well I think it was it's not only
the model from January 6th but Bannon
and Jason Miller and others affiliated
with Trump were advising jair bolsonaro
in November about quote next steps it's
like next steps dude you lost so it's
quite literally the same model the Q
Anon people seem to have potentially
been involved at least online in
fomenting what went on it's quite
literally a copycat thing and this was
exactly the concern
yeah I do think that um I don't feel
like there's going to be a whole like
hearing or something like that though I
can't really see that happening because
I think like he seems like he's been a
lot more silent than Trump has you know
yeah well he ended up in the hospital he
was he was in bolsonaro was in Florida
at the time and he went to a KFC he went
to a Publix and then he ended up in the
hospital with abdominal pain I mean it's
a dramatically different situation also
they did start arresting a bunch of
people pretty damn quickly down in
Brazil doesn't mean that it was
perfectly handled but it doesn't seem as
though it's all going to go the same way
yeah you know what's what's crazy is
like there were actually even more
people or someone I think the capital at
January 6 is like 3 000 and like at
Brazil was like 4 000 but like the area
was vacant so it was a lot less violent
but I don't have those numbers in front
of me but that that is interesting I
will I will look into that
yeah
all right Ty well thank you very much I
appreciate it
I mean thank you too that's my dog
barking all right you might want to hang
all right say hi to your dog for me
there is Ty from Iowa with some very
very powerful declarations
one of our sponsors is Helix sleep I
have been sleeping on a helix mattress
at home for years now I couldn't be more
happy with it I recommend it to
everybody the other day even though
she's not allowed in the big bed I put
my baby daughter on the mattress and
even she loved it Helix sleep is the
premium mattress brand offering tailored
mattresses based on your unique sleep
preferences take the Helix sleep quiz it
asks you about your body type your
sleeping position do you get hot at
night do you have back pain and then
Helix will match you with the mattress
that's perfect for you most people don't
know where to begin when shopping for a
mattress including me Helix makes it
simple and less risky because you know
you're getting a mattress that fits your
needs it ships free you can try it for a
hundred nights to see if you like it and
it comes with a 10 or 15 year warranty
unlike many mattress companies all Helix
mattresses are made in the USA by a
skilled production team so you are
supporting good jobs helix leap is
giving my audience 350 off plus two free
pillows this is the place to get pillows
you know what I mean go to Helix
sleep.com slash Pacman and use code
Helix partner the link is down below